nous sommes prêts pour vous un geste et
3 2
c'est le jour du public qui promet
d'être aussi éprouvant que le jour de
son couronnement
voici 25 ans le jour comme aujourd'hui
posez vous la question depuis que je
suis sur le trône caisse réellement fait
faux
[Musique]
le pays est en faillite maintenant
sécurité nationale et en langues
la volonté du peuple a changé si cet
homme gagne aujourd'hui il voudra nous
chasser nous pensons que la paix ne
durera pas indéfiniment
quand je suis devenue reine c'était un
grand pays regardait le bain tout ce que
j'ai fait c'est regarder le royaume uni
s'effondrer vous n'avez pas le droit de
traiter
il ne se défendre et que si nous
admettons qu'il s'est effondré c'est
ainsi la monarchie nous remplacerons les
fissures
[Musique]
la soeur aînée est la soeur cadette
numéro un et numéro 2 qui est nommé roi
toi
il le sait en plus oui je pense qu'elle
le sait
si vous me permettez deux petits cancers
ne jamais fermer la porte aux véritables
à vous
et le second méfiez vous de votre
famille ils sont bien intentionnés non
il ne le sent pas
chacun jouera le rôle qui m'est attribué
suis-je écouter dans cette famille
quelqu'un sait qui je suis ce que je
suis non
la colère et le ressentiment peuvent
s'accumuler pendant accepte d'être good
noah dû faire des sacrifices et a dû
oublier kg mais ce n'est pas un choix
c'est un devoir
photo
m